هذا تحد أردته وأتوقع أن
أرى أنه يفعل ذلك ولكن هناك
تفاصيل لا تتعلق بالطريقة التي
تلعب بها بجودة اللاعبين ، هل
ستحكم على جودة اللاعبين الذين
أحبهم ، لقد
كان لديهم مكان رائع  منهم
يفعلون ذلك لكن هناك التفاصيل
التي أه تعلم
أنها تأتي من النجاح الذي حققناه في
الماضي علينا أن نعترف بأننا حققنا الكثير من
النجاح ، يقول الناس لا ، إنه ليس نجاحًا
لأنه مع هراء في دوري أبطال أوروبا  لقد
فزنا كثيرًا في هذا البلد
بحقيبتين من دولارات الولايات المتحدة ، والطريقة التي لعبنا بها
بثبات ضد ليفربول هذا ،
ما هو النجاح
الطبيعي الذي يجب أن ننظر إليه على
أنفسنا ، هذا ليس كافيًا ، نعم ، لا
بأس ، لا تأتي ، قلت لك العدائين في وقت مبكر جدًا.
لا يمكن أن يسقط لأن العدائين مرة واحدة ولديهم
نصف الوقت ،
الجودة موجودة لهذا السبب
اشتريناها ، أريد مساعدتك في
الوصول إلى هناك ،
سأقوم بتحريكه
يسمى 55 هدفًا أريد تسجيل 50.
أريد المزيد للجميع
وأضع  لا يتعلق الأمر بالأداء الجيد ولكن
ليس هناك شكوى ويمكننا أن نفعل ما هو
أفضل وسوف نتحسن